Місцеві дороги не ремонтують?
Скаржтеся керівнику області.
З такою порадою міністр інфраструктури Володимир Омелян
нещодавно звернувся до громадян на своїй сторінці у Facebook.
За його словами, бюджет обласних доріг у 2018-му становить понад 11 мільярдів гривень.
Однак місцева влада їх недостатньо використовує.
Усього в Україні 170 тисяч кілометрів автодоріг.
Але з 1 січня цього року "Укравтодор" відповідає лише за 50 тисяч кілометрів
автодоріг державного значення, інші 120 тисяч передано в управління місцевої влади.
Саме вона тепер, згідно з децентралізацією, має опікуватися ремонтом доріг обласного значення.
При цьому велику частину грошей на ремонт в регіони відправляють з бюджету -
з Дорожнього фонду, який поповнюється за рахунок зібраних мит та акцизів.
Цьогоріч з фонду на обласні дороги виділили 11 мільярдів гривень.
Саме про ці кошти й говорив міністр.
На графіці, яку він оприлюднив, видно, що деякі регіони
станом на кінець червня встигли витратити лише близько десяти відсотків з цих грошей.
На це міністр і нарікає.
Cтаном на липень, повідомили DW, цифри не суттєво змінилися.
На думку експертів, головна причина тут у тому,
що це перший рік, коли дороги перевели у підпорядкування місцевій владі.
І більшість обласних адміністрацій не встигли організувати процес.
Лише в кількох областях створено місцеві держпідприємства,
які перебрали на себе функцію  Укравтодору на місяцях.
Ще одна причина - обласні адміністрації скаржаться на проблеми з проведенням тендерів.
Десь держзакупівлі затягуються через проблеми з документацією,
десь компанія, що програла тендер, іде до суду і тим самим затягує початок ремонту.
Окрім того, важко знайти в регіонах і якісних підрядників.
Разом з тим, малий відсоток використання коштів Дорожнього фонду не означає,
що ремонт доріг в областях взагалі не проводиться.
У місцевої влади є й інші джерела надходжень на ремонт дороги,
кажуть, в мінінфраструктури, наприклад, фінансування з місцевих бюджетів,
формування яких після децентралізації теж значною мірою перебуває в руках місцевої влади.
Місцева влада дійсно недостатньо використовує кошти, які Дорожній фонд виділяє на ремонт доріг.
Це пояснюють насамперед тим, що це лише перший рік,
коли дороги повністю перейшли у підпорядкування областей.
Утім, це не означає, що ремонт доріг в областях взагалі не проводиться,
бо існують й інші джерела фінансування доріг.